yeah yeah this is 100% my new favorite
t-shirt hi hello
unsure welcomes and greetings are always
the sign of great video ahead hi my name
is grace helbig if you did not know now
you know your life is different now I'm
just so proud of this 31 year old girl
that's stupid proud of this guys today's
big day today is national baloney day we
all collectively learned about this in
my video that was up last Friday go
watch that if you give any [ __ ] about
previous education and I told you I want
to do something to celebrate the holiday
at oh my god
have I done something this is a DIY
video but it's definitely a DIY video
actually no I stand by all of these DIYs
these are seen great and you would be so
lucky to be gifted one of these October
24th is national baloney day says
certain websites on the internet quote
national day calendar com each year on
October 24th people across the nation
make a sandwich to take part of national
Bologna day this would be a good day to
have a bologna sandwich for lunch
thanks to that fun fact national day
calendar that aside I think this holiday
is the best
and like most major holidays tis a time
to give a gift so today I am showing you
some quick easy cheap DIY gifts for
national Bologna day that you can make
for your friends and family last-minute
if you forgot about this extremely
important holiday let's do it first
thing we're news late on tarp then take
this piece of wood paint a color that is
like Bologna put some white dots and
black dots on it and you got yourself a
baloney cutting board / just baloney
piece of wood then we're going to take
some cork board trace the circle on it
cut it out paint it the color baloney
put some white and black dots on it and
you got a baloney coaster then we're
take a pumpkin paint the color baloney
put some white and black dots on that
you got yourself a baloney pumpkin never
take a ceramic dinner plate paint it the
color blonde you put some white and
black dots on that you got yourself a
bologna plate
then we're gonna take this emoji pillow
that I feel kind of like a pervert for
own except feel too old cut out two
different colors and below these circles
hot glue them together turn them inside
out stuff that emoji pillow in that
pillow case a hot glue a close paints
away two black circles on top of you got
yourself a baloney pillow there were I
take this here comes the bride tote bag
we found conveniently on Amazon were a
cross out the word bride we're gonna
rewrite the word Bologna on it and add
some decorations and then you got
yourself a here comes the Bologna tote
they're gonna take a hockey puck and
cover it as some baloney color foam
paper and paste some white and black
dots on it and you got yourself a
baloney puck last thing we're gonna do a
sick of brow and we're gonna paint it
blue on the colors then put some white
and black dots on it and then you got
yourself a baloney brow there you go
there's a bunch of national Bologna day
DIY gift ideas for you to make for the
ones that you love the most in your life
and also for the people you hate
national Bologna day does not
discriminate
unless you're vegan
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up so I know and don't forget to
subscribe to my YouTube channel by
clicking this button right here and I
don't know
let's hear some other fun facts about
Bologna from these websites
I don't like any of these back